i'm wearing this michael jackson shirt
well because michael jackson i beat his
guinness book of world records when i
was 10 years old for being the youngest
male solo artist to have four
consecutive uh singles in the top 10
billboard charts wow michael jackson
then reached out to my mom and said hey
i want to give your son the title of
prince of pop you can use that my mom
wrote a book called prince of pop and
then i did
a song with michael jackson he picked a
handful of people luther vandross celine
dion beyonce justin timberlake and me
and we did a song called what more can i
give and then i opened up within madison
square garden
on september 9th september 10 of 2001
and we all left the morning of september
september 11th and i saw the plane hit
the building like you're in a plane no i
was in a limousine i was i was supposed
to go on tour and michael invited us to
go to an amusement park after the show
so i was in the limousine going to a
private airport and i was across the
hudson and i was just standing there
like thinking oh i remember this from
like home alone you know and i was just
thinking you know whatever and then all
of a sudden i see the plane hit and
about four seconds later i hear it
and it was just it was crazy and then so
i i saw michael at the concert and i go
hey i'm going to get that jacket from
you okay he had that sparkly jacket on
the red one no no the one that's made
out of all swarovski crystal that's
worth like 35 million dollars
now um there's only two it's the right
one to ask for uh and i was like i was
like i was like i was like i'm gonna get
that [ __ ] review he kind of get glued
it off a little bit then i went to his
birthday party and you know his 47th
birthday party and i i literally just
grabbed the cake and i smashed it in his
face i didn't care i was like i'm gonna
treat you like a human being you know
what i mean did you get the the jacket
later that night
me my brother rodney jerkins michael and
raffle the executor of his estates and
we're all sitting down in his living
room and raffles leans over mike and
goes hey don't you have something for
aaron it comes out gives me the jacket
nick gets so pissed off he gets up
immediately and leaves
wow that's amazing wait this is because
now on 9 11. you were on your way on
your way to the airport after 9 11. okay
yeah yeah yeah this was just a matter of
like three or four different incidents
where we were together
um
what was your take on uh
on like all the the michael jackson
documentary neverland yeah that was that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] man wade robson bro
come on dude
i'm sorry but i was there
i spent plenty of nights with michael
i didn't see anything remotely close to
that
but you saw nothing about respect and j
and
and generosity
sure when i left
that neverland
i came back
uh because we used to live next door to
michael in san diego's
we had a rant out there but not at this
time
i leave get in the limo after his
birthday party ride his dirt bike around
i smoked weed with michael um
did he smoke a lot of weed is there
michael jackson
i've never heard of michael smoking weed
actually that's michael jackson's
supposed to read and i smoked me with
him
so that's a good one so and then
so i get but here's the craziest part
about all this
i get
back to the universal sheraton
right
and my parents had four
fbi agents and detectives there to talk
to me
and they're like did michael do anything
do you do anything dude and i'm like
the [ __ ] are you guys talking about what
year was that yeah how long ago was that
i mean
i don't even remember he was still alive
jojo right no he he remembers
he was probably still alive yeah yeah
yeah
youtube no no he was alive but to be
honest with you no no but to be real he
was struggling and we all know that
sure
it's not you know no it's not new news
well how old are you at that time
um like 13 or like 18. uh i was 16 16
15. and you went you slept over at his
place it was placed multiple times yeah
yeah are there other kids there at the
time
so it's just you you're just hanging all
day stay the night yeah i mean i think
it got to a point where because i
literally you know i'm pretty candid
i'll ask anybody anything i'll give [ __ ]
man like whatever
i i literally asked myself so what's up
with all this like little kid stuff
going on with you you know like why do
they do that to you he's like
he's like i don't know but i all i try
to do is is
reinstall myself
into new generations so that i keep
myself current
and i also never really had a childhood
so these when i hang out with these kids
they
they they give me a feeling of like you
know
fulfilling a void
in my heart he told me and i was like
well then why don't you keep doing he's
like because they won't stop prosecuting
me
they won't stop all these mothers and
that's what i'm trying to tell you is
when i left my parents had fbi agents
and detectives there to try to sue
michael
and i said no no no no no no get the
hell out of here all these [ __ ] guys
and
and then they left and then my parents
were all pissed off because they wanted
to do it on purpose
do you understand what i'm saying
sure they wanted to i don't find that
too
like your parents were interested in
suicide
they wanted to sue him because they
wanted to make up a lie because of what
was going on with all the prosecutions
there would be like a money grab yeah
yeah it's a money grab what do you do
with michael when you're just kicking it
with them are you guys like smoking a
joint
me michael and chris tucker went riding
around on four-wheelers and mountains
for like three or four hours um
you know michael jumped into the uh his
alligator pit started swinging around
his alligator tail in the middle of the
day like he was just a goofy fun guy man
you know and if you treated him like a
person you didn't have you know
uh you know like star struck or whatever
and people are people man like i've met
everybody you know like i've had elton
john come to multiple concerts of mine
and i didn't even know at that time you
know like i've i've
my dad was best friends with bruce
willis like you know like he would come
over all time i went to rumors bruce
brought me in to do rumors sweet 16. you
know um it's just
i just i've met so many people that
along the way you know that
that's just you know it is what i mean i
i dated mel b from spice girls for you
know the facts
and we used to tour together when i was
9 and she was 20
my girl loves the spice girls
yeah dude yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude